bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée comme vous le savez
à l'actualité sportive dans le
département tout de suite le sommaire de
votre émission
le sky rugby après la tête du
championnat de promotion d'honneur en
s'imposant dans la difficulté contre
clermont ce week-end de 27,1 les détails
dans cette édition football féminin
montigny-le-bretonneux se déplacera sur
le terrain de calais pour le 1er tour
fédéral de la coupe de france pour nous
parler de cette rencontre nous recevrons
sur ce bateau le président olivier
biancucci la gardienne jennifer est
guéri et la coach valérie mercier cher
leader second plan un sub sur la section
des templiers d'elancourt une structure
créée en 2012 pour soutenir les
footballeurs et qui compte 18 membres
cette année
et puis en fin d'émission tour d'horizon
des résultats sportifs du week-end dans
le département nous parlons notamment de
boxe et de la victoire par ko de l'élan
courtois a dit lahm ou m'a dit c'était
le choc de cette 7e journée de promotion
d'honneur le sky rugby deuxième du
championnat recevaient le leader
clermont au stade du bout des coûts de
maurepas un match qui a tourné à la
faveur des yvelinois le score 27 à 20
les images sont signés à mélanie poké le
chef de la 7e journée de promotion
d'honneur à tourner à l'avantagé du sky
rugby les vert et bleu deuxième du
championnat avant l'heure rampante l'ont
emporté avec difficulté contre le leader
de la poule clermont à domicile que ce
corps est serrée 1 27 avant cet hommage
très compliqué qu'on a bien entamé
donc on a malgré qu'on est pressé on a
réussi à enchaîner tout de suite prendre
le score ce qui les a fait se pousser à
la faute prendre des cartons et du coup
on a pris ce corps et cette équipe si
pour eux d'essayer de recoller au score
du match les saint quentinois
dominateurs en première période ont dû
s'employer après la pause pour garder un
avantage au score
le duel a été intense jusqu'au bout
clairement réussi à marquer une pénalité
un drop pour revenir
à cette pointe des illinois dans les
cinq dernières minutes deuxième étape le
plus difficile pourtant on avait le vent
dans le dos on n'a peut-être pas su
gérer comme il fallait mais on a pris
quelques points n'a réussi à garder le
score pour nous et voilà la fin à la fin
ça finit bien qu'attendu avec cette
victoire le sky rugby reprend la tête du
classement avec un bilan de six
victoires en six matches les saint
quentinois sont premiers avec 24 points
un de plus que leurs adversaires du jour
est fixé comme objectif par 160 victoire
pour l'instant on y est et si on veut
remplir notre objectif qui est de monter
en division d'honneur on est obligé de
tout gagner d'un qui on devait gagner
pour tous moments passés premier donc
maintenant les premiers c'est nous et à
eux de venir nous chercher pour rester
premier continue à rêver de la montée le
sky rugby affronte le dimanche 6
décembre rosny sous bois à domicile
après le ballon ovale en passe au
football coup de projecteur sur la coupe
de france féminine
nous continuons donc ce magazine par la
coupe de france féminine monty bretons
ne se déplacera le week-end du 15
décembre sur le terrain de calais pour
le 1er tour fédéral de la compétition
pour nous parler de ce rendez-vous nous
recevons sur ce plateau olivier bancoult
biancucci seul le président la gardienne
jennifer guéri la côte cheval ailé merci
bonsoir
alors comment avez-vous réagi réagi
olivier noguchi au tirage au sort quand
vous avez appris que ça serait calé bon
je pense que c'est un tirage qui est qui
peut nous être favorable déjà la chance
qu'on a c'est de jouer une équipe qui
n'est pas supérieur à nous il me dh
voilà en fait c'est une équipe de dh
donc ça peut être de bonne augure pour
atteindre le deuxième tour fait d'armes
même avis valérie tout à fait
a park au niveau de la commande dans le
nord ils sont beaucoup plus agressifs
quoi le jeu n'est pas le même par
rapport à la à la région parisienne donc
c'est quelque chose que vous appréhendez
pts à 3 un petit peu oui un petit peu
occupé et votre côté vous les jouez vous
en avez discuté entre vous mais ça fait
toujours ça ça fait plaisir déjà d'une
de se déplacer parce que pour la plupart
d'entre nous c'est un peu la première
déjà de ma part c'est la première fois
de se déplacer aussi beau et ça fait
plaisir mais après c'est vrai que comme
dit valérie c'est une équipe qui est
assez agressive et nous dans notre show
nous on n'a pas encore mais pas encore
assez agressive donc ça va nous
permettre de travailler à ce niveau là
olivier est ce qu'il n'ya pas une petite
part peut-être de déception sachant que
les clubs de ligue 2 de deuxième
division arriver là pour ce premier tour
fédéral est ce qu'il ya une petite
déception de ne pas recevoir un club de
deuxième division
bon je pense que la déception avait été
teintes car si on a la chance de passer
ce tour
ça nous permettra sûrement de se
déplacer sur une équipe de d1 car au
prochain tour fédéral il ya les équipes
de première division qui vont rentrer en
liste donc une déception non pas trop et
puis bah comme alizée jenifer le fait de
se déplacer
ce sera aussi une fête pour tout groupe
donc c'est un petit peu la récompense de
ce qu'ils ont dû tout le travail qu'ils
ont fait depuis le mois de septembre est
ce qu'on peut dire que ça sera du 50 50
oui oui concrètement mais c'est du 50-50
tout le monde a sa chance
voilà maintenant nous on part avec l'
envie de gagner il envie de passer ce
tour
et puis la vérité du terrain fera le
reste
comme on dit et est ce que le fait de se
déplacer dans le nord au mois de
décembre
il fera froid est-ce que c'est un gros
désavantage pour je pense pas je pense
que on allait jouer dans l'habitude de
jouer qui fasse le show qui fasse froid
je pense pas que ce soit un désavantage
je ne connais pas le terrain peut-être
qu'il sera gelé à cette période de
l'année
non non je ne pense pas non non pas leur
pareil pour vous les joueurs non je peux
on a été tout à confronter à des
situations match où il pleuvait à
torrent
et sous la neige même au dernier tour de
coupe de france qu'on a on a joué sous
une pluie torrentielle et ça ne nous a
pas empêché de faire un super match pour
que l'on s'attend un peu à toutes les
conditions climatiques nous est apte à
jouer sur toutes les conditions
climatiques et quels seront les recettes
valérie pour pour remporter ce match
comme je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
l'agressivité je pense que ça va être
vraiment un facteur important
ensuite ça va dépendre en fait si vous
voulez de l'équipe d'effectifs de
l'équipe parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
des joueuses qui sont qui sont plus ou
moins dans le commerce des joueuses qui
sont dans la police donc on ne sait pas
encore tout à fait l'effectif mais on se
rend en début de semaine prochaine
donc à partir de là on s'adaptera en
fonction des joueuses mais bon
l'agressivité c'est vrai que ça va être
vraiment primordial vous êtes la
nouvelle coach de monty nous est arrivé
il ya quelques semaines à un mois
sa bio que tu as début octobre quel sera
votre discours pour motiver vos troupes
discours si solidarité agressivité ils
concentration et vous appuyez votre
message sur quels aspects depuis vous
êtes vous êtes arrivé à la tête de
l'équipe une c'est déjà une bonne
cohésion de groupe et c'est aussi le
plaisir de jouer mais c'est aussi de là
progressons voilà c'est difficile de
reprendre un groupe a derrière un
entraîneur alors qu'elle la saison déjà
commencé mais
on a essayé de garder le même jeu quoi
le même système de jeu sans trop sans
trop perturber les joueuses donc un jeu
plutôt offensif oui en fait si vous
voulez on commence à faire un pressing
après les filles derrière savent déjà ce
qu'ils ont à faire
olivier on va revenir ce match de coupe
de france est comment appréhende un
match comme celui là est ce que la
motivation est naturelle
oui moi je pense que les filles seront
motivés naturellement en plus le fait
qu'on se déplace en quarts car le club a
quand même souhaité prendre un car pour
ce déplacement donc on partira très tôt
le matin donc déjà le groupe son
ensemble dans le car pour ce qui est du
froid je demanderai à permettre de
chauffage comme ça ça me tueront un clip
la température mais non l'appréhender
non non non j'espère tu de moins que des
filles dans leur techniquement pas
d'appréhender moi j'aimerais qu'ils le
prennent vraiment comme une fête déjà sa
veux dire vraiment qu'ils apprécient ce
moment et de là je pense qu'un résultat
positif sortira je pense vraiment qu'on
reviendra sur votre plateau pour
prochain tir je l'espère jennifer
comment la pression comment on commet la
gère
dans ces matches là est ce qu il faut
pas peut-être ne pas jouer
le danger c'est peut-être justement de
jouer ce match dans sa tête avant le jeu
sur le terrain est ce que est ce que
justement il ne faudra pas faire c'est
je pense pas que c'est une très bonne
idée de jouer le match dans sa tête
avant parce qu'on peut ça peut vite
changer enfin non je pense pas que ça
importe je pense pas que c'est important
déjà on va pas penser ou là la
difficulté on va où va se battre et puis
donc pour moi non ce papa se refaire le
match pas commencé le match et est ce
que vous pensez que le groupe est assez
fort pour supporter cette pression ne
sont déjà depuis la saison on a fait des
matches un peu sous pression et ça s'est
bien passé et je pense qu'on est toutes
assez forte tu es d'accord à valérie
vous êtes d'accord
oui je suis tout à fait d'accord et
principalement la concentration d'avant
match aller elle va être très très
importante et est ce que vous allez
peut-être plus privilégiés on sait que
c'est un match qui va se jouer sur des
détails
vous êtes deux équipes du même niveau
est-ce que vous allez privilégier
l'attaqué qui fait votre force
finalement dans ce championnat où est ce
que vous allez vous allez privilégier
peut-être un jeu plus défensif avec un
bloc plus bas sur le terrain je pense
qu'on va on va jouer comme on le fait
d'habitude on verra à peu près quoi par
rapport à la température de l'équipe
je pense que au début on va jouer comme
il en a l'habitude de jouer et jouets
offerts impressions verreault
je suis en mesure du match président
quels sont les objectifs du club sur
cette compétition assure cette
compétition naturellement cd il faut
impossible maintenant la coupe de france
c'est pas notre priorité valérie de ces
on en a déjà échangé tous les deux après
le tirage de du tour du bost lui et
c'est du bonus c'est vraiment c'est
prendre quoi c'est cadeau maintenant on
ira plus loin possible
on ira en fera tous les matches avec
l'envié de gagner et puis il a vraiment
une très belle fête ce serait vraiment
de quitte à sortir que au moins ce soit
en d1 pourquoi pas aller à lyon prochain
tour
marseille voilà ce serait vraiment une
belle fête quoi et est ce que vous avez
à votre avis les moyens de vos ambitions
elle est d'aller d'aller encore vous
être sur ce tour je gagne dix de gagner
peut-être encore wayne à un match toute
attente d'après vous savez la personne
commence à se prononcer un petit peu du
tirage
donc voilà donc là on a un tirage qui
nous est pas favorable mais qui nous est
pas défavorable non plus donc
aujourd'hui l'ambition c'est de passer
ce tour
valérie on est d'accord et après à après
on verra par rapport à l'équipe rongera
naturellement premiers matches les uns
après les autres
voilà sur la pelouse de france je pense
qu'il faut vraiment prendre les matches
les uns après les autres car ces tirages
qui détermine beaucoup de choses aussi
mais quel est votre plus grand rêve ou
en tant que président mois pour votre
club dans cette coupe de france d'aller
battre lyon au prochain tour notre
audience prolifèrent oui oui d'aller le
plus loin possible
ça serait super valérie japon 6 e tour
ça serait ce serait vraiment bien je
pense que ça sera un mauvais du bonus
merci à tous les trois le passé sur ce
bâton vous souhaite bon courage pour ce
match contre calais et on espère vous
recevoir à nouveau sur ce plateau comme
on l'a dit il ya quelques instants pour
le prochain tour on passe à présent au
judo
la 23e édition du tournoi international
de trappes était organisée ce week-end
au gymnase paul mallet cette année
encore les judokas ont répondu présent
250 sportifs sont venus d'île de france
de bretagne et du nord de l'hexagone
mélanie poquet à pour les images c'est
une véritable tradition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la 23e édition
du tournoi international de trappes
était programmé ce week-end au gymnase
paul mallet cette année plus de 250
participants se sont affrontés sur les
tatamis
j'apprécie ce que c'est un tournoi dans
les yvelines dans mon département et
depuis tout petit j'ai l'habitude de le
faire donc je fais chaque année ça reste
quand même un gros tournoi l'année
dernière c'est un échec promener sur le
plan du niveau le niveau reste très très
important il ya eu gervais des garçons
du pôle france du pôle espoir donc ces
bandes et le niveau de jeu est vraiment
très très élevé pour cette édition 2015
la compétition internationale avait
seulement une résonance nationale le
tournoi n'a tiré que des judokas
français venus d'île de france de
bretagne et du nord et sportif et roger
ont décliné l'invitation d'annie moment
les combats sont programmés bons qu'ils
soient là ou pas là ça change rien au
point de vue organisation ça n'est pas
ça nous perturbe pas bon ça nous manque
parce que bon on a toujours plaisir d
accueillir des bombes à
voilà c'est comme ça les événements ont
fait que malheureusement c'est comme ça
qu'on n'y peut rien c'est vrai que c'est
embêtant parce que c'est vrai que
c'était aussi un moment où les étrangers
enfin vous pouvez côtoyer d'autres
cultures d'autres façons de travailler
le judo est malheureusement cette année
c'est un petit peu restreint malgré
l'absence des étrangers le tournoi
international de trappes devrait être
reconduit en 2016 pour une 24e édition
on continue ce magazine par un pari fou
le pistard de vélizy 78
jean michel richefort va relever le défi
de rouler pendant 24 heures sur la piste
du vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour le téléthon l'exploit
est programmée entre le vendredi 4
décembre à 18 heures le samedi 5
décembre à 18 heures nous recevons sur
ce bateau le cycliste pour qu'il nous
parle de son aventure bonsoir jean
michel richefort bonsoir alors expliquez
nous la question de la question est
simple est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce défi incroyable
oui c'est un défi un peu fou comme vous
l'avait annoncé
et effectivement mais moi je suis un
homme de défi des défis paris brest
paris ça a été pareil pékin en 2008 et
l'a tout naturellement avec ce vélodrome
il fallait faire quelque chose notamment
eu les championnats du monde
mais là on n'est pas dans la performance
sportive on est dans un défi d'endurance
et il fallait également montré que
le cyclisme sur piste et par les
porteurs de valeurs de valeurs humaines
et le challenge c'est de faire ce
passage entre le sport et puis le
téléthon tout simplement essaha défi qui
vous trotter peut-être aura-t-elle
depuis plusieurs années oui parce que
j'aime bien
les efforts d'endurance et j'aime bien
rouler longtemps un rythme régulier
et là la piste le cyclisme sur piste
c'est avant tout des épreuves de vitesse
1 le sprint le kérygme épreuve de
produits les plus en vue
là on est dans l'endurance et pour
marquer les esprits c'est parti aussi
d'un pari avec mes camarades de l'équipe
cycliste vélizy tout simplement les
pisseurs de belize qui se sont illustrés
dernièrement donc au grand prix de la
ville de vélizy sur le vélodrome de
saint quentin et comment a réagi votre
votre entourage
quand entre entourage a appris la
nouvelle quand on l'aura bien donc
au contraire ils ont été très
enthousiastes et ils ont dit il faut
relever le défi on va t'aider à relever
ce défi
y compris tout le staff du vélodrome
toute l'équipe technique du vélodrome
l'équipe de vélo police qui a tout mis
en place pour réaliser ce défi il faut
savoir que ce défi constitue le fil
rouge du téléthon pendant les deux jours
au niveau du vélodrome nationale et moi
en fait je ne suis qu'un prétexte pour
faire venir le maximum de cyclistes oui
c'est beaucoup dire parce qu'il y aura
bien sûr des animations il y aura des
concerts et
la fin de ces deux jours le bouquet
final de ces deux jours de fête ce sera
le concert de sanseverino le samedi soir
et donc pendant votre périple vous allez
être entouré oui c'est un sur votre vélo
mais il y aura également d'autres
cyclistes qui vous accompagneront
pendant ces 24 heures voilà parce que le
but
effectivement c'est de recueillir des
fonds - chaque tour de piste accompli
contribuera donc à augmenter et
augmenter l'enveloppé mais aussi les
cyclistes qui vont bien combien par tour
ces deux euros partout on zéro partout
voir et j'espère bien accomplir 2500
tours de piste ce qui ferait 625 km
voilà mais le but également c'est de
faire venir tous les copains de la piste
les habitués du vélodrome mais tous les
pisteurs de tourner avec moi déjà pour
me tenir compagnie pour pour
m'accompagner
donc il y aura des créneaux d'une demi
heure et ils apporteront ainsi leur
contribution au téléthon et donc ça se
passe comment rouler avec vous ah non il
grave il faut s'inscrire avant mais
également il faut être un habitué de la
piste avoir fait au minimum un baptême
pour venir sur la piste on ne monte pas
sur la piste surtout sur cette piste de
saint quentin qui est très technique
on ne vient pas avec son vélo pour faire
des tours de piste on s'est réservé
quand même à des cyclistes aguerris mais
il y en a beaucoup dans les yvelines
dans l'île de france et même j'ai des
amis qui viennent
de loin qui vont venir de bretagne de
l'orléanais qui vont venir de dijon
également pour rouler avec moi c'est
pour vous aider bien sûr bien sûr parce
que les six premières heures entre 18h
et puis 24 heures bon ça ça ira mais à
partir de 2 heures du matin c'est
difficile et c'est surtout en fin de
nuit la fin de nuit le petit matin quand
on a 12 heures de vélo dans les jambes
avec la fatigue un peu le sommeil hélas
les copains seront là pour m'encourager
et je pense que j'en aurai bien besoin
justement quand allez-vous descendre de
votre vélo parce que vous allez pas
rester 24 heures innocent m vélo c'est
allé faire des petites pauses de temps
en temps c'est tout est programmé toutes
les heures il est prévu de faire une
pause de cinq minutes entre cinq minutes
et huit minutes ne serait ce que pour
s'hydrater pour s'alimenter également
pour
se faire masser également hélas est
prévu une pause rapide et puis on repart
et on a prévu en tout et pour tout trois
heures
d'arrêt donc ce qui fait 21h sur le vélo
et donc je devrais si tout va bien et si
la progression bon tout ça c'est
théorique parce que il ya beaucoup
d'inconnues un également aventure c'est
un peu l'aventuré mais je suis confiant
dans la mesure où je suis très entraîné
je me suis vraiment bien entraîné on a
fait des simulations sur trois heures
sur six heures et après dans le final
votre journée type haut niveau à
l'entraînement est ce que vous vous la
décrire oui alors les journées types sur
les deux derniers mois
alors j'ai fait des semaines uniquement
sur la route entre 600 et 800 km mais
une journée type d'entraînement là sur
le dernier mois ça a été deux heures de
piste le matin 80 km l'après midi et un
second créneau de deux heures le soir
est depuis longtemps depuis deux mois
avait bu deux mois et est ce que le
corps humain est fait pour supporter 24
heures de cyclisme oui le corps humain
lorsqu'il est entraîné à des grossistes
et les médecins se défiler passa sans
l'avis du corps médical je suis suivie
au niveau
cardio pulmonaire j'ai fait un test
d'effort et c'est une épreuve
d'endurance donc ce qui compte c'est la
régularité
on ne puise jamais au niveau cardiaque
on ne va jamais très loin dans l'effort
on est régulier et lorsque on s'alimente
régulièrement s'hydratent correctement
avec des pauses régulières on peut aller
au médecin sera de nouveau
il y aura là médical avec un médecin est
incliné bien sûr
et est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
c'est peut-être le plus grand défi de
votre vie de cycliste
parce que j'avais ce sentiment là c'est
un défi parmi tant d'autres j'ai fait
également d'autres défis notamment des
défis en montagne
mais c'est un c'est un très très beau
défi je ne sais pas si ce sera le
dernier défi parce que il faut toujours
se lancer des défis dans la vie mais en
tous les cas c'est sûrement l'un des
plus beaux défis nous avons récompense
de votre exploit une fois qu'il sera qui
sera terminé tout simplement
si je fais faut pas parler d'exploit si
je relève le défi et si je le réussis
c'est surtout pour la bonne cause c'est
contribuer modestement donc à la cause
du téléthon et apporter une contribution
donc à l'afm ça c'est le plus important
mais aussi créer une animation et
fédérer donc autour du cyclisme sur
piste sur le vélodrome national avec
toute l'équipe de vélo pauliste est tout
tous les amis qui vont venir me soutenir
en fait c'est ce qu'il faut retenir ce
serait l'image la plus belle donc les
gens sont venus soutenir pour la bonne
cause
merci à vous jean michel richefort
mercedes à ce plateau bon courage merci
moi personnellement je n'aurais pas fait
bon passer maintenant l'autre zoom sur
les cheerleaders des templiers
d'elancourt ans le cheerleading a été
créée à la fin du 19e siècle aux états
unis ce sport à et s'est rapidement
greffe au sport national comme le
football américain et le basket en
france la discipline grandi depuis une
dizaine d'années une section a même été
créé en 2012 pour soutenir les templiers
d'elancourt pendant leur match de
football américain roma reste finit à
pour la montage
bon slogan encouragements show à
l'américaine à la mi temps nous ne
sommes pas aux états unis mais à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis 2012 une
section de cheerleaders a été créé à
elancourt leur mission soutenir les
footballeurs des templiers l'une des
meilleures équipes de france pendant
leurs matches
il y avait énormément de filles qui
venaient encourager leurs compagnons qui
joue au football américain
et c'est comme ça que ça s'est monté
lors d'un match on s'est dit et pourquoi
pas créer une équipe de cheerleaders
cette année la section comprend deux
catégories seniors et juniors au total
18 filles se sont inscrites pour la
saison 2015-2016 des templiers ce qui
m'intéresse surtout c'est vraiment
d'encourager les joueurs je suis
vraiment là pour je suis avec eux je
vais vraiment qu'ils gagnent d'un autre
côté aussi comme il ya du public on est
là pour les entraîner avec nous à les
encourager
c'est ma première avec ce fait du
cheerleading et
parce que tout ça a fait film américain
entré 10 mai porté sous chorégraphies
synchronisées le cheerleading est un
sport qui allie à la fois la danse et la
gymnastique
c'est vraiment fort ça mélange à la fois
chez nacicca la fois dense à la fois
porter donc c'est vraiment physique
déportés sont très physiques parce qu'il
faut avoir forcément ma force pour pour
porter les filles
après c'est surtout beaucoup
d'entraînements beaucoup de régularité
et voilà c'est surtout ça le plus
important
et quand même énormément d'acrobaties
déportés il faut aussi être très tonique
parce que quand vous quand vous faites
des chorégraphies qui dure cinq minutes
avec des portes et il faut être sportif
il faut avoir du souffle et tout ça
évidemment gardant le sourire
ces deux dernières années les
cheerleaders des templiers se sont
produits de stade charléty à l'occasion
des finales française de football
américain les élans courtoise pourrait à
nouveau se produire en juin prochain
devant plus de 6000 spectateurs pour une
troisième finale
on passe maintenant aux autres résultats
du week-end dans le département
on commence cette rubrique résultats à
part de la boxe l'élan courtois a dit
lahm ou m'a dit qu'il s'entraîne au
palais des sports d'el hank ou a
conservé sa ceinture de champion
d'europe des poids super-moyens évinois
battue en italie à milan le transalpin
giuseppe brute cetto sur ses terres donc
on va les durées 42 donné favori avant
la rencontre a dit lahm ou mady a
terrassé son adversaire par un ko dès
les premières minutes du match
le protégé de la team farrugia devrait
combattre à nouveau dans les prochains
mois pour conserver sa ceinture
on termine ce magazine par un
rendez-vous basket le club de le s et le
fc trappes reçoit ce samedi à 20 heures
val de seine dans son gymnase paul
mallet pour le compte de la 8ème journée
de fédérale 3 les matches les hommes
coachés par mustapha et la fille sont à
l'heure actuelle dans le bas du
classement après leur défaite du
week-end dernier contre juvisy 66 à 58
les yvelinois ne seront donc pas favori
contre les deuxièmes du championnat mais
ils pourront compter sur leur pivot de
stars de deux mètres aux jo et cassius
pour l'emporter
rendez vous samedi à 20 heures pour les
soutenir celles à 27,8 sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
magazine très belle soirée sur tv fil 78